problema número 198 si un medio más un
tercio más un cuarto es igual a 13 entre
x cuál de las siguientes opciones de
aumentar estas son nuestras opciones
bueno pues primero vamos a resolver esto
cuánto es un medio más un tercio más un
cuarto vamos a encontrar el común
denominador este va a ser 12 6 por unas
6 6 por 2 12 son 6 12 abós que es lo
mismo que un medio aquí escribo 6 más el
siguiente que número x 3 me da 12 es 4 3
por 4 12 y este 1 también lo tengo que
multiplicar por ese 4 me va a dar 4 12
años más cuatro más que número x 4 me da
12 pues es 3
así que multiplicó 3 por 4 12 para tener
este denominador y multiplicó ese 3 por
el numerador para mantener la igualdad 3
por una 3
cuánto es 643 va a ser igual a 13 12
años y si nos fijamos vemos que aquí
está este mismo 13 entonces acabamos de
encontrar x este es x ahora que ya
conocemos el valor de x vamos a ver cuál
de estas nos da un entero 12 entre 8 no
nos va a dar un entero porque 8 no es
factor de 12 esta no es 12 entre 12 si
nos va a dar justamente un entero este
si nos da un valor entero
/ 24 nos va a dar una fracción de hecho
nos va a dar un medio así que este no es
un entero por lo que nuestra opción 2
corresponde al inciso b
siguiente pregunta
problema número 199 en el siguiente
sistema coordinado la línea x
dice acá perpendicularmente al segmento
ave que no se muestra y el eje x dice
que perpendicularmente al segmento veces
que tampoco se muestra si la coordenada
de a es 23
cuál es la coordenada del punto c hoy
vamos por partes
recordemos que cuando algo me seca
perpendicularmente quiere decir que
divide a la mitad y forma un ángulo de
90 grados con la línea que vi seca
tomando en cuenta el punto a en donde
deberá estar el punto b para que esta
línea xy volái en la parta por la mitad
perpendicularmente bueno aquí a ojo yo
puedo decir que este punto b va a estar
en la coordenada 3,2 más o menos por acá
este va a ser mi punto b con las
coordenadas 3,2
varias razones por las que podemos
intuir que esta es la respuesta correcta
pueden ver que la pendiente de ave está
de acá va a ser de menos sur
recordemos nuestras clases de álgebra si
tenemos la pendiente de una línea por
ejemplo esta de igual a x que es 12 o
pendiente la pendiente de una línea
perpendicular tendrá que ser inversa y
negativa a la primera el inverso
negativo de 1 es menos 1 así que el
segmento ave está sobre la misma línea y
son equidistantes al punto 22 este punto
2,2 tiene la misma distancia este y este
así que este segmento ave pasa acá así
que lo vi seca y tienen la misma
distancia sea pasa por la mitad y es
perpendicular forma un ángulo de 90
grados muy bien ya tenemos nuestro punto
b ahora nos dicen que el eje x biseca
perpendicularmente el segmento bc que
tampoco se muestra pero bueno aquí lo
vamos a encontrar entonces este es mi
punto b me falta mi punto c
y lo va a atravesar perpendicularmente
entonces este segmento debe ser paralelo
al eje y vamos a dibujarlo en otro
colorcito un rojito entonces debe ser
vertical paralelo al eje y ahora tenemos
que ver que la distancia del eje x
avn sea la misma que del eje x ac y debe
hay 122 unidades hacia arriba del eje x
por lo que mi punto ce debe estar dos
unidades por debajo del eje x va a estar
más o menos por acá
de hecho quito el sobrante y aquí está
mi punto ce cuyas coordenadas son 3 en x
y menos dos en y así se cumple que el
eje x lo divide a la mitad o lo vi seca
y lo hace de manera perpendicular así
que veamos las opciones de esta
coordenada resulta que es nuestra opción
d
a este problema estuvo bastante
interesante siguiente problema problema
número 200 una tienda vende todas sus
toallas al mismo precio si el precio
actual de cada toalla aumentará en un
peso 10 toallas se dejarían de comprar
con un total de 120 pesos sin incluir
impuestos cuál es el precio actual de
cada actual si dividimos esta cantidad
que nos dan los 120 pesos 120 entre el
precio de cada toalla que lo vamos a
llamar p esto va a ser igual al número
de toallas que puedo comprar no sé
cuánto vale le estoy llamando en el
número de toallas a comprar me dicen que
si este precio aumentar el 1 sí tengo
mis 120 pesos entre el precio de la
toalla más uno que se incremento podría
comprar esta cantidad n menos 10 toallas
n menos 10
entonces aquí tenemos dos ecuaciones con
dos incógnitas está la puedo expresar
como p por n se multiplicó todo por p p
por n es igual a 120 y esta puedo decir
que se multiplicó todo por temas uno me
va a quedar 120 igual a temas 1 por n
menos 10
vamos a hacer esta multiplicación 120 es
igual a por n menos 10 p más n que es 1
por n menos 10
vemos que estas dos ecuaciones son
iguales a 120 así que podemos decir que
esto es igual a esto vamos a escribirlo
aquí p por n es igual a b por n menos 10
p más cn menos 10 bueno vamos a
simplificar esto estos dos elementos se
pueden ir nos va a quedar que 0 es igual
a menos 10 p más n menos 10 sumamos 10 p
en ambos lados y nos va a quedar 10 p
igual a n menos diez ok tenemos esto
pero está n
aquí la tenemos y es igual a 120 entre p
entonces puede usar esta para sustituir
aquí y me va a quedar 10 p igual a n
pero n la sustituyó por 120 entre p 120
es un -10 vamos a multiplicar todo por p
me va a quedar 10 p al cuadrado igual a
120 120 menos 10 p muy bien ahí vamos
ahí vamos voy a dividir todo entre 10 y
me va a quedar lo escribo de este lado y
en otro color para que sea variado esto
pero al cuadrado es igual a 12 - p bueno
vamos a dejar esto como una ecuación
cuadrática vamos a poner que p al
cuadrado más p menos 12 es igual hacer
todos estos términos los pasé para acá
con signo contrario y ahora éste la
tengo como una cuadrática entonces vamos
a factorizar la que parten números
multiplicados me dan menos 12 pero
sumados me dan 1 pues va a ser entonces
p 4
p - 3 igual a 0 4 x menos 3 es menos 12
y 4 menos tres me da 1 así que esto lo
corté entonces los valores de p
podrían ser p igual a menos 4 para que
esto sea 0 o igual a 3 pero como estamos
hablando de precios pues una cantidad
negativa como que no tiene mucha lógica
ya que no vamos a estar regalando las
toallas esto es lo que vamos a estar
cobrando así que este precio va a ser
igual a 3 pesos y esta es mi opción si
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo